сьогодні у нас собі виїхав покращення
кадру посвіти я моїй базі кадру в
закуплених своєю професією
багато людей відблиски для яких професія
вчителі природ равлик плями будуть центру
вам цей талант хочу
ранку вам від обожнювання теж часто неп
керує всі професії, щоб
розуміти нас кікі води буду тек навіть не
проти ресурсу і завись порожнім
як щоб ти пізно контингент наших
педагогічних університетів та повернулася
на пріоритети який собі смачну гітлера
наказ хорошим результатом за ним то
тому злодій до тестів я до запасних ой
данчик і в нас нема і допливу молодих
тикових кабель учительської професії
таким чином професія старіша і тих хто
красивий тут бересте і навичкам ентузіазмі
любов'ю такі професії там крима та с
он і ставиться старшими та старшими
церква така одна ось на площі нації
щури і крок краще нації щури що уго
році вшити ля
і вимкнув cinq євротур цей годинник і годинник
на 1 вересня на день вчителя
гнучкий на прикиньте початковому руку
чиновники починають виворот і протягнувши
цієї ситуації франко
від всі мережі sain aber пакет
відпочинок чити хоча адам лакхов
тому що цинія накид верджі осіб з
зростанням зарплати в 4 і чому я прошу для
гору так можна сказати брутально
кришталевий зарплати в 4 2 крок шуму
підніму
на тарифну сітку а я чоловік ілон маск
відвести rsa добре вам центри пізно ти
зовсім бюджетникам ми оплачуємо
зарубати на плату вид повірила до
тарифні сітки титри внесіть я розряди
старшого за 20 таку житель вищої
категорії пустельні красиві чіти
позиційного по своїй зарплаті на
одинадцяту розряді а assistent ви
клада ча вищій школі на п'ятнадцятому
розряд той хто який
розрив mistland apple за тіла nuits f4u
школі а сьогодні в читу в школі in Мар'є
вплинув ну так факти випадку
школу проходити абсолютно все і це я
депо затягнутися супротивники вищі школи
звучанням на мою думку і там і там
ти що зарплата нижче анапа війна всередині
обшитий або драматично лише і за раз ми
назвали china душа скрутимо фінансову
економічну ситуацію плану йому ходж ap
трах та g у бюджеті 2017 просунув ти в
катарі скуштуйте в чіп а в згорі нашу
позицію щодо соціального статусу жителя
вислали у проекті закону право світу
є просіяли сьогодні вам говорила я
пив і жити у великому не ракетнику з
різних соціальний статус статус вчителя
буду its a тaм yax саму позицію ну і себе
у чати та аки ерівань кваліфікації вин
травня
боях що у нас батьки ось і батоги і с
так вже правда і про це треба частина
нового ринку зустрічаються з медболом
ставлю ним 4 до дітей
ситуація ми голі дитину підриви та
травми у школі мораль метро
психи літрів коли шитий
trojan св
авторитет кращих дитин і ось шах батьки
випадково що тут я так вже проблема
дикого такос пожувати до виставлення су
spaced вода вчителя тому що ми не
хотілося av2 праці тюбик думали, що ви
хоче avi праці тесті їй 2 і системи до
свити
тому що радіанс до вас вигляд його
на працювала на рогинський суєт нам трава
творить з остину і до процедури
ділянки на затиску ukranian all is ваги та
так сам виправити як російської школи я
взяла допомогу рутини тур 4 тому що підлозі
так і мікростан і правда
бочкарів злочинності ти ти лени моїх
право погано але місто f4 на бачили
чверть до порожніх полиці ви не можете
пити з лісу ватої ситуації
ситуацію з враховувати аліною допуск ати
оку волю в цій річці спосіб сором і
натиснути і провалився витрачаємо і тому
буду річардс авторитет в 4 та його со
спини назвою нам треба звучать з них
владою а порубає і свій шматок роботи
мегі а молитви кімнатою свою роботу
зростання повідають чіп профарбований 4 патоки і у
нас є чудовий до свят і нам теж чим
ми зараз піцу йому над проектом які б
тоді парасолькою той же початку початковому
руку
c куртки відео уроків 4 які покаже
мабуть і туди викладання саме для
тіла компетентнісного підходу ночі
ви куба читаючи петром 4 років 4 столітті
світиться і пігмей допрацьовувати всю
музику радисти прапор gettin таки моя мої
завдання до я для себе патчів від
міністра усвяти
зруби ти створ цієї важливої ​​влади щоб
так у
родись і знанням збивала крима ти
шкіряний український вид і на у школі та на
поклади чи такий віктор, щоб вона
доторкнулася до фарбування шкіл випадково що з
складні проект борються на це шум та
моєму 17 з половиною тисяч ки жодних
процу я хлопчик фільми і нападав про
особистих противників
царі проект на 10 літер йому
і що ми на цю ж труби і чому ми зараз
гіршому прийнятий закон чому ми чому
взятися за створення цієї концепції для
щоб у нас був аполітичний тягнулися
в такі реформи пари форма вас вид його
на вона соромиться ось енрік а у нас
змінюються курять і парламент і міністри ви
зараз правий шлях кругових виборі
підлий з від virgin реформа
це мова в диких клінік на наказ у
канаді нами раз побачив та one та піт
підписував та
між політичними сином і таку воду ще
ми приймаємо, що у нас буду реформам
святі та стрибучих їх нових політичних
конфігураціях ми продовжуємо навчати про
formulas види за вискочить ці впали ти
чмо тягнулися нам дуже важливим